في خان يونس شيع الصحفي الفلسطيني اكرم
الشافعي الى مثواه الاخير بعد استشهاده
امس متاثرا باصابته حين كان يغطي الاحداث
من داخل مستشفى الشفاء بمدينه غزه خلال
الاسابيع الاولى من الحرب ولم تنجح
محاولات عائله الشافعي على مدار الاسابيع
الماضيه لاخراج نجلها من قطاع غزه للعلاج
بالخارج وارتفع اجمالي عدد الصحفيين الذين
استشهدوا منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى
نحن اليوم نودع
ونزب
الشهيد اكرم احمد الشافعي رجل تعرفه غزه
بكتاباته وبانتمائهم
الاحتلال الصهيوني قتل حتى هذه اللحظه
اكثر من 100 صحفي هو يحاول في هذه المجزره
ان يحيد وان يستهدف الصحفيين اما بالقتل
او بالاصابه او بالاعاقه او بتدمير
منازل الصحفيين وقتل اهلهم اليوم قتل
عائله زميلنا الصحفي محمد عوض صباح اليوم
وبالامس استشهد اكرم وقبله استهدف عائله
الدحدوح وائد الدحدوح وغيره من الشهداء
الصحفيين هو فقط يريد يوقف
الصوره